welcome to this video this is a new
video about my tournament games yes you
probably know I recently played a 9round
Swiss system open tournament in bad visa
but we say is a little town in Bavaria
and it was the open bavarian
championships very strong open
tournament maybe the strongest open
tournament of Germany there is another
one and now in that died sizzle like are
open but but this is probably the
strongest um it's it's quite on the same
level as the other one yeah this is sent
a big tournament 480 participants which
is some at the same time great and and
at the same time a little bit of a
problem because this many participants
means that it takes quite a long while
in the service system tournament until
you get very strong opposition and this
is what you need for scoring those
desired norms for IM or GM um yeah we'll
talk about this a little bit later when
we come to the the future rounds or the
rounds like 45 and so on this is the
first round game and the first round
means that the whole tournament gets
separated into an upper half and the
lower half in terms of rating and the
upper half rating group plays the lower
half which means I'm a huge favorite my
opponent here was a german player Edwin
Lehman rated about 1950 and yeah I was
black and he opened with aha 1f for you
don't get that too often it's been years
since I face this move it's not a very
common move of course um and with some
justification it's certainly not a move
that um gives wide lots of hope for an
opening advantage but what opening
really gives you my job there are always
problems so if you know move like f1 why
not
play it once in a while okay um I wasn't
totally sure what to do I mean there was
no preparation here you just get your
get to know your opponent a couple of
minutes before the round so I just had
to do something here over the board
normally I play d5 here but I was
remembering an interesting idea that has
saw in a book once I went d6 after like
two or three minutes I just wanted to do
something creative yeah what is the idea
of the move that there are multiple
ideas one idea is that if white plays
efore now which is of course not a bad
move it didn't play it but it's a very
obvious move of course um black has
ideas like like this Knight f6 a little
bit quick I'm sorry I didn't want to
jump there Knight f6 93 and d5 this is
quite an interesting way to play um gap
why why is this interesting yeah it's a
little bit comparable to a line of the
scandinavian defense or the Lacan with
93 but here white has played the extra
means f 4 which is not very helpful to
him it mostly weakens the king and we
will get an open center now or we get
things like this he 5d for quite
interesting yeah this is one of the
ideas of this 66 line another idea is
some like after this 9003 this is
actually what my opponent played black
plays Bishop g4 this is what I did and
now White has to react to the idea that
black threatens to damage White's porn
structure he went III sort of you are
keeping along the typical setups that
are associated with their form before
again was possible after that black girl
play something like this yeah and then
d5 aiming for maybe a position like that
we something like that which is a little
bit like a French defense but the bishop
is outside of the pawn chain here on g4
and we get in c5 later this is certainly
an okay position of black this is one of
the ideas of this this type of setup
however after this he went with III not
bad um okay I want to do play in the
center of course so I go e five and now
he traded TM and developed with Bishop
e2 I was of course quite satisfied him
this is some just okay for like I get a
free piece development and have no
problems whatsoever my original
intention here and I probably should
have played it anyway was to capture and
go if all that's quite nice because I
cannot take blunders piece so why
probably has to play something like this
and then black can't play an active move
like Queen g5 intending Bishop the 69 f
697 maybe or 96 and maybe long castles
this is a nice position I have an active
Queen however during the game I wasn't
so sure if I want to give up the best
bishop pair that early and I was
thinking that maybe I can um just
develop and keep the bishop for now I
went with 96 which is not bad at all so
we just have pretty normal development
developing moves and now we played for
the somewhat surprising move Queen to
you one I didn't expect this move I was
thinking you should probably play d 3 or
reform moves like that it doesn't feel
very realistic that the Queen gets
active here but in fact it's not that
bad at first I was thinking that night
before has a good reply taking here but
Jeff checking this a little bit in more
detail reviewed that you can just go
back and the question is what exactly
has night before accomplished
after move like a 3 later I just have to
drop back again and I didn't didn't gain
much from that something like a 495 is
it's not at all clear with those ideas
here take care take on f7 it is just not
clear so I decided to not play in night
before but to develop with Queenie 7
preparing long castles which is also a
good move simply he went before and I
played long castles there were some
alternatives but nothing truly
spectacular 94 was an idea to use the
default square but after takes takes a
night b5 what is not in such a bad shape
I can go Bishop b5 but something like
move like like this intending to not
there to go to go to see for later it's
not that bad for while I mean I have no
problems but it's nothing that promises
black a lot so my move long castles
wasn't really bad he played d3 and now I
went age 6 I just wanted to prevent
Bishop g5 not necessary but also not a
bad move he played Bishop e3 yeah and
here I begin to make them start to make
second rate moves now um I played King
b8 now kind of a bit of a lazy move my
rationale was that this move is always
necessary for various reasons it keeps a
seven Cabot I mean you can put it on the
board King bee aid it keeps this
cupboard on a seven ended in cases of
this night jumping to the 4g for he is
not hanging with a check those kind of
ideas make king b8 useful however I
largely under man and underestimated his
reply what I should have done is I
should have played Bishop c5 here when I
had still had the chance after this we
will get get the
bishop's traded for example on something
like this and then 94 here black has a
slightly more comfortable position
mostly due to the fact that the bishop
only two is not a good piece it is
nothing decisive but black is a little
bit a little bit more comfortable and
it's I think would have been pretty
logical opening resort given that right
has played somewhat passively here um
however as mentioned i went king to be
eight and what I underestimated was
exactly what he played he played Queen
f2 and I really thought that while this
isn't a great move right I just dropped
back to e6 which is something that I
want to do anyway because the bishop on
g4 is not doing much and I'm threatening
Nyjah for now winning material my idea
was okay he has to probably play h3 was
my thinking and then I can play maybe
like 97 Bishop c5 this kind of with this
kind of idea trade the bishops one while
also transferring the night to the to
the sender however he had has a much
better movie played night h4 and i
really had underestimated this move the
idea is that it gives white this
possibility Knight to f5 nothing
spectacular something that I should have
seen but I somehow didn't really
register that this is much better than a
three okay still nothing terribly wrong
with blacks position I played 90 for
attacking c2 ought sauce until went
bishop do you want looks a bit bit
passive but it protects c2 and he still
has this idea of night f5 yeah and here
I wasn't really sure what to do to be
honest um night f5 is coming and I
originally had intended to play em yeah
to play with
move Bishop f5 and Bishop c5 at some
point but I was recognizing that he
always has this reply and I mean I
cannot allow him to take this and if I
job back ok he will happily drop back as
well not that he needs to do that but I
mean I want to win the game was black
being like 500 points higher rated so I
cannot just repeat moves and somehow i
went to play Knight to d7 and this is
really really bad I mean I cannot really
tell you what I was thinking to be
honest I mean because it with hindsight
it's really a release really silly move
I in fact why does not threatening that
much here um and I can play yeah sort of
awaiting the compounds to play something
like this it's just basically really
waiting and yeah let's say after this I
can take and go from here this is a
better version of the game you will see
this quite quickly 97 is really really
stupid okay let's let's go back in this
position I played 97 yeah of course he
went night at five I have to take and
here I I really recognized that I'm in
trouble I mean it's really embarrassing
a bit because now it's pretty clear
night to e4 and the only real way to to
play against it is to play the night
back to f6 I need to challenge the
knight on e4 and another thing was that
the Bishop c5 move here again runs into
94 this is objectively by the way the
best move but the problem is after night
a4 I still I cannot go to be six looks
very stupid he just takes it and after
Bishop d6 back he just repeats with a
draw and I cannot draw a drawing round
one here in this tournament
against a 1900 player so um I had to do
something else and yeah what I did is I
am I just returned young very stupid all
this but somehow i stumbled into this
into this troublesome position and he
barely played as well he played 94 now
you're just putting this night in the
middle of the board and the main point
is that mine died on d4 which looked
quite nice is now getting kicked with c3
yeah I mean here I realized that I'm in
deep trouble and I spent quite quite
some time but I really couldn't find
something good young maybe you can
debate that the next move is also not
not great but it is a problem anyway
because what happens in the game will
basically happen on any moves I went
here to to make a 7 I mean to reduce
this pressure here here here yeah I'd
here in this position he had a he had a
very nice opportunity he went and
relatively quickly went with Bishop f3
Bishop f3 is quite logical and keeps an
advantage simply because white has the
much better pieces yeah those bishops
are great and he's got a great night on
e4 and my pieces on d6 and c6 I just I
mean just stupid um that was not bad but
even better was to play be formed
attending a form after that I'm in big
trouble really i I really don't know how
I would have continued him it's just
just very very bad i saw that but I
couldn't really find anything to play
against it something like this is
probably probably the toughest defense
this was one reason why I went a 6 of
course i was aware that this is the
weakness here but i wanted to make this
night
oba maybe get a counter play on f5 or
something white can just play a move
like b5 here open up the position it's
really terrible I don't know where that
would have been able to save the game if
you had found that a very a very nice
position for wide yeah I played Bishop
f3 which helps me a little bit a little
bit i can go 95 now and this means that
he either has to give up one of the
bishops or yeah retreat his bishop in
fact a good move for white here still is
before me this is not as powerful as it
was before but still still excellent for
white it's it's something like this
maybe Queen d7 and Bishop c5 is is also
quite big advantage for white he has
better pieces he has an attack a4 b5 and
I have very little counter play so so no
Bishop f3 as mentioned it's not a
mistake it just probably not the most
precise move and TM after after before I
again having big trouble but fortunately
for me he now made a mistake and this is
in fact a pretty typical mistake that
that sometimes happens in games of
players of that level he made a wrong
exchange he took on d6 instead of this
he took on d6 um and this I really I was
very relieved when this happened because
it was quite quickly clear to me that
the worse now is over I can just take
with the queen of course it is two
nights against two bishops that's true
so there was some some rationale behind
the capture but the issue is that I'm
directly threatening to get one back
here one of the bishops and if he moves
a bishop away you like like this there
is also this night afore idea i can just
go back I just have counter plague
the deep or no yeah this is maybe the
most convincing one so here I'm out of
I'm out of the woods anyway especially
if you compare the knight on e4 was
fantastic against the stupid bishop on
d6 so I really have gained a lot you
played Bishop before now and here i
already could have taken on e3 I wasn't
sure I wanted to do something else I
played Knight to f6 and I had the
structure of the game in mind that now
happens and I think this is a good
decision because it gives black some
some winning chances not in a not better
but it has some imbalance coming Queen
to have three years is good and are now
traded on e4 and entered only three yeah
note the transformation many pieces have
been exchanged and most of the pieces
were really awkwardly placed for black
and now I have some play on the default
and on d3 there is a weakness yeah he
already was I was very satisfied however
it is still nothing nothing great
happening one important point is that we
have a situation where white has the
good Bishop yeah a dark squared Bishop
with light square pawns but this also
means that the bishop cannot defend the
pawns yeah so a combined attack maybe
like this not a seven all the way to see
a 2d six and with the Queen will
probably win me the e4 pawn this is the
idea that I had this imbalance that I
wanted to have um yeah it's still
nothing nothing great rook f2 to cover
entry squares Queen B 5 was okay yeah
until you should play be three with the
position that is still roughly equal
nothing i'm terrible happening um how he
made a mistake or ever played rook to d1
and I immediately am I immediately
committed
a mistake as well I'm after Luke g1 we
have the first moment in the game where
I can really get get the better position
and this would have been possible with
the move Queen to see form and this is a
pretty obvious move attacking here and
here and it's not clear how he defends
those pawns yes to play some passive
move to do that of course I saw the move
but I was thinking and this was a very
very stupid mistake I mean I made many
mistake in this game I was thinking that
after the capture on the one instead of
this it is essentially the same thing
and I thought that this is probably even
better because the queen is passively
placed on d1 I actually I saw his reply
and he played it Queen d5 but I made a
very silly miscalculation I was thinking
that this move isn't that great actually
because I can take and play 97 this was
what happened in the game but what I
overlooked it is that he can actually
play the move f6 now I saw that but I
what I didn't see is that after the
capture rook takes 95 I was thinking
that this is a double attack and white
has to do something like rook f3m
basically being a pawn down I can he can
take on age 6 and this is what I didn't
see beforehand when I allowed the Queen
d5 move for white fortunately for me
after this my opponent didn't play f6 he
was obviously am somewhat worried about
the d5 pawn and he just played the move
see form after c4 White has spoiled this
chance to get the get the better game
after f6 he would have been somewhat
better because other position opens up
and this Bishop is just stronger than I
but now after f6 the position is quite
closed and after Bishop c5 98 I was
feeling quite okay again yeah it is
still nothing brilliant for black but at
least them I'm not in trouble anymore
which I was with this f6 idea yeah look
at three is what he played intending to
attack my g7 porn this is one problem
the g7 porn is weakness and the bishop
the bishop on c5 at the moment dominates
my night um and I don't want to play
move like night to d6 allowing any
further simplification yeah in fact here
i was thinking okay what what can i do
would you somehow win this game I mean
it's still a fairly passive position and
I came up with an idea that I think is
okay especially from a practical point
of view I went c6 and starting here and
even a bit further a couple of moves
earlier I started to play really quickly
because I wanted to somehow get him into
into time pressure I felt like it needs
some some some mistake from why do for
me to win the game so c6 interesting
idea after the capture I went b6 this
was my idea the ideas that I can
actually activate the king and support
further night move to d6 or maybe to e7
another right circumstance here he
played a surprising move at least it was
surprising to me the move Bishop to e3
it is not yet a problem this move but I
was far more expecting something like
this or to be formed simply looking at
those crucial squares that man night
cannot be activated after that I think
white enjoys a small advantage
I can play King c7 something something
like this it's nothing serious I think
black should should be able to to hold
this but yeah definitely you see that
the bishop is well placed I cannot move
the night easily it will lead to some
infiltration for example on the six or I
mean it's clear that the bishop is is
better there than on III but it did not
happen after b6 he went to e3 nothing
not something that lens wide into
trouble but I think it's giving away a
little bit of ground King c7 and now he
played Rock g3 which is not leading to
to too much but it's also not a big
mistake yeah rook h7 I have to do that
it looks it looks ugly but we shouldn't
underestimate that f5 is somewhat
isolated and will get attacked by the
night this is in fact a drawback of this
rook g3 move if you look at this he now
went be three um and then just to show
you what I mean I go 9790 yes to go back
so Rupert III didn't really net white
anything um however instead of b3 he
also had an interesting alternative he
could have played c5 here that was an
interesting time after c5 I have to go
b5 and our Bishop f2 intending to switch
over here yeah a5 rook a 3 a 4 goob d3
King c6 group d 897 this was an
interesting idea for white which however
i think is not totally clear it look Sam
it looks awkward but I definitely have
counter play with the attack on it five
it's a position that the computer
estimates is about equal but it's
difficult I mean it would have been
still a good fight note that this c5
move is interesting because it gains
yeah white gets a passer
and white has ideas like that but it
also makes their own bishop a little bit
of a problem peace it's looking at its
own porn and not attacking anything
though situation is not clear but it
would have been interesting for wide to
try he didn't do that however he played
the movie 3 yeah I now activated the
night he had to return with the rook and
now aged 5 I don't need to take c6 right
away my idea was with h5 I wanted to
play h form rook age 5 and then grab the
pawn a pretty straightforward plan and
it turns out that exactly this plan was
successful in the end due to a mistake
on my opponents part and one problem
also was that it didn't have much time
left we are on move 36 now and yeah he
didn't he didn't have much time he went
Bishop see one now which is not doing
much but also not not a mistake White
has interesting ideas however though
after king of two for example which I
didn't really take into account much and
because i thought okay age form let's
say here and now Luke h5 this was my my
intention and however this isn't that
great in fact after the great moves look
h3 black isn't some trouble this is a
motif that we both overlooked the idea
now for white is to play G form very
very strong means that I cannot take it
just a very strong fork at take with the
rook you can take care and we recognize
that my rook is trapped I have no square
there is this idea and there is this
idea and why just let out wins quite a
remarkable idea this rook age three so
my idea with h4 h5 was yeah interesting
but it shouldn't really work he could
have ignored it yeah he didn't I
ignored he played the move Bishop to see
one as mentioned i took here bishop here
to control d4 and i went with h foyer
still following up on the idea here the
most now it was muth 39 he made a
mistake i think with rook age three he
still has good chance is to keep the
position because 97 again can be
answered by a g4 utilizing this the
spinning motif rook h3 was still quite
okay for what nothing great happening he
played h3 however and now after night
after Luke h5 I'm sorry he went with G
for that was this wasn't a DM initiating
count to play against g7 okay I really
cannot do much here I have to protect it
and right here here yeah he made the the
decisive mistake of this game Black is
already a bit more comfortable because I
have the better structure I have to pawn
islands well black has free and he still
has weaknesses like at five to attend to
however move like rook f3 now still
would have been very tough as rook h5 is
always answered by rock g3 and 97 it's
not leading to much because of this
attack in order to make some progress I
i think i would have played something
like b5 trying to gain squares like the
d5 square for the night and then maybeee
form these kind of ideas i mean i'm
pretty confident that i can i can play
this for a win against the somewhat
weaker opponent but it's objectively
speaking nothing brilliant for black
yeah however you played the move King f2
and after that I just go 97 and wind
horn rucca three ruge age five and he
cannot keep the pawn so King f2
basically gave away this gave away the
pawn yeah and with it the game actually
when f five drops the whole position
collapses we M went to this end game no
black is upon up and in fact with rook
with 96 I'm immediately attacking this
week pawn before wasn't helping really
but there really was no no better
defense after King before here I went g6
and after that movie resigned as he
cannot prevent f5 check and the capture
on c5 after which black has two extra
pawns and young connected passes in the
center yeah this was the first round
game and it was a lucky lucky game
really I had many many tough spots where
he could have gotten a good position I
just want to quickly go back to this
point when we were in them around the
opening here here he could have gotten a
fantastic position with before this was
the the toughest spot in the game he
didn't do that he took on on d6 which
helps me quite a lot and later he also
missed the chance to get an advantage
with f6 when I was overlooking this
resource like here he could have pushed
f6 with the better game so a very shaky
start those first rounds are sometimes
tricky or somehow not really yeah you're
not really in this tournament mode um
yeah what what what can I say it was a
bit of a bit of a lucky win um and he
missed some some some chances definitely
yeah I hope you enjoyed the game it was
a was a fighting fighting game and I
hope you will watch the further coverage
of the tournament it's nine videos total
11 per game and they all had some
interesting points there was no no
boring game whatsoever among the nine
yeah okay thanks for watching